the fact that we're back after three
years of hardship and dark times I think
this is the kind of life that we need
we're definitely gonna have to be
dancing to the audience again for sure
we're definitely going to be dancing to
the audience again
[Applause]
love love love creating with my wife
and whenever the kids want to join in
it's the best capturing our hearts with
this So You Think You Can Dance audition
oh my God
Steven twitch boss began to rise to
stardom captivating audiences with his
beautiful performances
fall asleep
it was love at first dance for twitch
meeting Allison hoker on season seven of
the show as an All-Star
[Music]
if you could spin I could spend the rest
of my life with you
sharing three kids together Allison and
twitch often share their love for dance
and their family online
of course twitch went on to do big
things most notably becoming Ellen's DJ
and later executive producer of the talk
show over a decade ago I met someone who
changed my life and and our show and I'm
talking about you twitch in the
statement to E.T Allison confirms the
passing of Stephen writing in part
Stephen lit up every room he stepped
into he valued family friends and
Community Above All Else and leading
with love and light was everything to
him Stephen we love you we miss you and
I will always Save the Last Dance For
You
[Music]
TMZ was first to break the news
reporting that he died by Suicide which
ET has confirmed twitch was only 40.
according to E.T twitch checked into the
Oak Tree Inn on Monday and when he
didn't check out the next morning Hotel
staff found his body on the floor
something you would like to say to
Twitch like what has he meant to you
well I don't want to say goodbye many
celebrities and fans of twitch have sent
their condolences online and of course
paying tribute to her late friend Ellen
writes I'm heartbroken twitch was pure
love and light he was my family and I
loved him with all my heart I will miss
him please send your love and support to
Allison and his beautiful children
Wesley Maddox and Zaya twitch one last
time
dance with me
[Music]